ce qu'ils ont bien fait de s'excuser
pour c'est pas des excuses qu'ils ont
formulés il en clair mais après moi je
suis franchement je suis vraiment
fasciné par la tournure de ce débat en
fait on part du postulat que les
musulmans se sont se sont insurgés on
avait qu'on soit clair laisser moins vu
se termine et j'ai écouté je vous
demande juste deux minutes on est très
clair si vous épluchez concrètement tous
les tweets qui a eu en dessous vous en
avez 99% qui émane de l'extrême droite
pourquoi parce que quand enfin il faut
un moment donné c'est poser la question
deux pour quelle raison est ce que hier
soir damien rieu membre très actif de
génération identitaire était déjà en
live sur télégramme pour parler de cette
polémique pour quelles raisons est ce
que quand on analyse les outils twitter
pour savoir qu'elle ne compte on
contribué à propulser cette polémique en
top twin
quand on sait qu'il est attendu sur
monsieur goldnadel avocat de général
sont identitaire damien rieu identitaire
connu et reconnu
or habitants grande gueule elle aussi
connu pour poser ce débat oui c'est pas
ça le décès de décision et on vous
remettez pas en question j'ai répondu
que s'il oublie trouvez moi un musulman
avec un nom prénom qui sent pas un fake
est où 1 1 et je m'excuse si ces paroles
et que je m excuse
est ce que j'aimais ce que vous pouvez
nier que le fait que les ions s'excuse
et bien la preuve qu'il ya un climat
qu'on n'a jamais connu auparavant et que
ce plateau on trouve quand même deux
personnes pour soutenir une thèse aussi
délirante que evian l'aurait fait exprès
le premier jour du ramadan je trouve ça
très haut les faits par acquisition à
quelque chose dans les têtes de très
inquiétant mais c'est le lot que je vous
pose la question trouvez nous s'il vous
plaît un musulman avec un nom un prénom
identifiés sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'ils puissent venir témoigner ça vous
savez aujourd'hui j'ai été contacté même
pas seulement par tpm paix par
énormément de deux rédactions qui me
disaient voilà est-ce que vous pouvez
venir bah en fait en gros endosser cette
position de dire voilà je puis en fait
vous avez bien fait de le préciser votre
moule pourquoi vous êtes là ce soir oui
j'ai juste les gens il a pourquoi elle
est là besoin c'est qu'elle dit que
cette polémique
pour elle elle a été créée par des gens
que evian a été instrumentalisée et
qu'il ya pas de mu mots qui se sont
insurgés contre cette pub que c'est
c'est mais voilà qu'ils se seraient pas
mis en a certains qui est ratée du
quercy fait qu'ils nous disaient jeu et
viande n'aurait n'avait pas à s'excuser
l'émission n'aurait pas dû se séparer
ils ont clarifié et caen et quand vous
êtes et vous les êtes bien placé pour le
savoir et moi aussi quand on est harcelé
sur les réseaux sociaux parfois on est
obligé de faire un deuxième tweet pour
que ça cesse pour que ça s'arrête pour
que les gens comprennent que en 140
caractères des fois on n'a pas de quoi
expliquer en grand pompe est beau
maintenant après la question qui se pose
à moi je pense qu'il n'aurait pas dû
réagir plein louis mais oui mais je le
dis je ne vois que les fiancés monde ont
préféré un jeune et c'est vrai parce que
c'est la seule qui a un ph neutre
oui et pour ma peau pour mon épiderme
c'est magnifique